unser tagesgespräch bei phoenix heute
mit agnieszka bürger denn mitglied im
verteidigungsausschuss des bundestages
für die grünen sitzt sie dort und es
doch stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende größe ganz herzlich
afghanistan raus oder bleiben was sagen
sie also wir sehen nach 20 jahren
militärischen aber auch zivilem
engagement in afghanistan dass die lage
nach wie vor hoch dramatisch ist und es
ist jetzt eben völlig unklar wohin es
auch mit der neuen beiden
administrationen gehen soll wir kriegen
anzeichen dass der einsatz verlängert
werden soll aber ich glaube ein einsatz
zu verlängern von dem niemand mehr weiß
welche perspektiven welche ziele er hat
ist natürlich extrem schwierig deshalb
ist es total wichtig die weiteren
entwicklung abzuwarten aber leere
durchhalteparolen alleine sind noch
wirklich keine substanz auf der man eine
solche schwerwiegende entscheidung auch
im deutschen bundestag treffen kann
das heißt sie machen sie abhängig von
der politik der neuen beiden regierung
wir werden als grüne bundestagsfraktion
das gebietet auch so ein bisschen der
respekt vor meinen fraktionskollegen und
kollegen natürlich jedes mandat das die
bundesregierung uns als parlament gibt
sehr kritisch sehr aufmerksam prüfen und
auch natürlich die lage in afghanistan
immer wieder neu reflektieren die
gespräche die donald trump mit den
taliban geführt hat die haben eigentlich
die probleme in afghanistan noch weiter
verschärft denn die afghanische
regierung war nicht mit am tisch die
taliban berufen sich jetzt auf dieses
abzugsdatum sie drohend aktiv die gewalt
noch weiter hochzufahren als ich es
gerade ohnehin schon tun wenn dieses
abzugsdatum nicht eingehalten wird und
wir sehen natürlich so viele
strategiewechsel in den letzten 20
jahren und trotzdem ist es nicht
gelungen die ziele zu erreichen da muss
die bundesregierung sehr viele fragen
beantworten wenn sie da die zustimmung
aus dem parlament möchte und wenn sie
selber entscheiden könnten jetzt so ganz
für sich würden sie sagen weiter
engagieren oder nicht ich sehe die
brutale realität in afghanistan ich habe
mich in den letzten jahren persönlich
sehr schwer damit getan einem einsatz
zuzustimmen wo ich selber keine
erfolgsaussichten mehr sehe wo die dann
auch soldatinnen und soldaten natürlich
ein sehr gefährliche situation kommen
und wir haben immer wieder
verbesserungen eingemahnt ist es immer
viel zu sehr auf das militärische
geschaut worden die politischen fragen
sind vernachlässigt worden korruption
und klientelwirtschaft auch dieser
regierung sind ein riesiges problem die
regionale lage ist kompliziert ich werde
aber trotzdem das neue mandat und die
neuen entwicklungen immer wieder auch
neu prüfen aber bisher habe ich
persönlich den einsatz aus dem grund
abgelegt okay das halt manchmal fest an
dieser stelle vor 20 jahren vor fast 20
jahren waren die grünen an der
entsendung beteiligt seitdem 57 oder 59
tote soldaten
fehler wurden gemacht haben sie gerade
schon gesagt haben wir daraus gelernt
haben sie daraus gelernt
ich glaube das ist ein ganz wichtiger
punkt ist wir fordern schon seit langem
eigentlich auch nicht als einzige
fraktion im deutschen bundestag dass die
militäreinsätze unabhängig und kritisch
evaluiert werden müssen damit wir aus
den fehlern lernen und ich glaube wir
sehen bei sehr vielen
militärinterventionen dass sie die ziele
die am anfang damit verbunden worden
sind nicht erreicht haben wir sehen
gerade in afghanistan ist es durchaus
auch immer wieder zeitfenster gab wo man
eigentlich hätte mehr machen müssen
hätte mehr zivil investieren müssen auch
in den staatsaufbau und dass diese
chancen verspielt worden sind diese
gespräche mit den taliban die donald
trump geführt hat waren eine weitere
verpasste chance auch die wahlen die wir
in den letzten jahren hatten waren immer
so momente des aufbruchs und der
hoffnung und aus meiner sicht ist es
total wichtig dass die bundesregierung
sich dieser kritischen evaluation nicht
verweigert sondern dass wir ganz genau
hinschauen
wann unter welchen sehr engen
bedingungen kann auch ein militärisches
engagement einen beitrag zur sicherheit
und stabilität leisten wenn wir
beobachten ja immer wieder ob es im irak
in afghanistan oder in mali ist der
kurzfristige aufbau von
sicherheitskräften führt nicht zum
erfolg wenn es nicht die entsprechenden
politischen reformen gibt und da
es ist eine ganz wichtige baustelle für
die nächsten jahre da haben sie schon
den nächsten punkt angesprochen der
natürlich ganz wichtig ist was können
die afghanen selber das gilt natürlich
auch für andere länder
was wir vielleicht gar nicht leisten
können mit unseren einsätzen also die
frage noch mal anders formuliert können
westliche armeen politische strukturen
so verändern dass sie demokratisch
werden
nein es ist eben keine aufgabe allein
von militärs das ist auch nicht das
wofür sie ausgebildet sind sie können im
besten fall in bestimmten situation für
friedensprozesse absichern überwachen
sie können sicherheit schaffen wenn es
gelingt aber das alles kann nur von
dauer sein wenn es die entsprechenden
reformen im land selbst gibt da sind
eben klientelwirtschaft korruption auch
unter dieser afghanischen regierung ein
großes problem
auch die nachbarstaaten die immer wieder
mit ihren eigenen interessen
intervenieren und dabei nicht das wohl
der bevölkerung im blick haben also
jetzt ist auch schon einen deutlich
größeren regionalen ansatz gebraucht und
das sind so fragen die immer wieder von
der bundesregierung vernachlässigt
werden und dann reagiert man mit anderen
mandaten mit mehr soldatinnen und
soldaten
aber das kann dann eben nicht zum erfolg
führen und das ist so eine bittere
wahrheit der wir einfach ins auge sehen
müssen und aus der wir lernen müssen
dass wir diese politischen prozesse
nicht derart vernachlässigen dürfen ich
habe selber von soldaten in afghanistan
sehr oft die frage gehört warum hier
eigentlich politisch zu wenig passiert
eine persönliche frage sind sie
pazifistin vielleicht noch eine weiter
gefasste frage ist sind die grünen eine
pazifistische partei die grünen sind
keine partei die kategorische nein zu
jedem mandat sagt sondern wir haben sehr
enge vorstellungen davon wann ein
militärisches eingreifen unter dem
primat des zivilen wie ich es gerade
geschildert habe auch erfolgsaussichten
haben kann wir sagen aber eben auch
nicht blind ja sondern wir prüfen jedes
mandat sehr kritisch also pazifismus im
sinne von militär niemals so nicht aber
wir sehen schon dass eigentlich die
entscheidenden fragen immer sind die
konflikte ursachen in den ländern
anzugehen und wir sehen dass
nach wie vor viel zu oft auf das
kurzfristige militärische geschaut wird
was auch gar keine aussicht auf erfolg
haben kann wenn man es eben nicht mit
den konflikt ursachen verbindet und die
politisch angeht sie könnten ja auch
vielleicht in einem jahr
verteidigungsministerin sein wenn die
grünen mit der cdu csu regieren
da kann man nur in diese richtung so wir
haben es natürlich noch nicht wie
schaffst dann aus mit der
regierungsverantwortung soldaten
entsenden vielleicht sogar an kriegen
beteiligt sein vielleicht sogar
bewaffnete drohnen befürworten
ich sah es ja mit am tisch
bei den verhandlungen zu den jamaika
sondierungen und das waren fragen über
die wir sehr ernsthaft aber durchaus
auch sehr kritisch damals mit der union
und der fdp diskutiert haben die frage
was aus mir wird ist angesichts zum
beispiel der bitteren realität in
afghanistan und dem neuen mandat
wirklich nichts was mich persönlich
aktuell beschäftigt aber wir haben da
sehr fachlich über diese fragen
diskutiert es gibt mandate die wir als
grüne im bundestag auch mitgetragen
haben zum beispiel die vn
friedensmission in mali und im sudan
trotzdem hätten wir auch da noch ein
paar verbesserungsvorschläge und
zugleich gibt es eben auch fragen wie
afghanistan wie den einsatz im irak wo
wir durchaus größere bedenken haben die
mandate nicht mitgetragen haben und dann
auch entsprechende fachlich fundierte
veränderungen drängen weil sie sonst für
uns auch nicht zustimmungsfähig wären
also das machen wir sehr an der sache
orientiert und auch mit einer großen
verantwortung für die
sicherheitspolitische lage in den
anderen ländern denn die ist uns
wirklich nicht egal
ein blick in die vergangenheit und auch
beim blick in die zukunft dafür bin ich
ganz herzlich agnieszka programm